say your baby is sleeping you just want
to know if his tiny little heart is
beating it's perfectly normal he repair
it feels like Little House on the
Prairie to admit that when my first kid
was born all we had in the way of
surveillance was the equivalent of a
one-way walkie-talkie I was a new mom
and I thought I needed it now we're in
the midst of a tech revolution that's
changing childhood way more and for the
worse it's the constant digital
surveillance of our kids there are five
devices that are turning moms and dads
into the NSA it's perfectly normal
you're a pen today there are literally
hundreds of baby monitors on the market
that stream live video and many are
infrared so you can hear in the dark as
your baby snooze is under his Mozart
nabil some models pivot and tilt which
seems like the sort of tool that might
appeal to seal team six but parents it's
perfectly normal you're a pen then there
are all the gadgets you can attach to
your baby like the owlet monitor a lot
uses pulse oximetry to monitor your
child's heart rate and oxygen levels and
give you that data in real-time right on
your smartphone you know your blood
oxygen level why are we treating healthy
babies like they need neonatal intensive
care it's perfectly normal your pen
making parents afraid for their kids is
a goldmine for companies which explains
the coming arrival of smart diapers that
help parents analyze the chemical
content of their babies output if I'm
getting dehydrated if my kidney
functions are normal if I got a nasty
UTI brewing because how dare you toss
such a vital diagnostic specimen just
into the
it's perfectly normal you're a pen once
the kids venture out there's a tsunami
of tracking devices that allow parents
distract the equivalent of an FBI ankle
bracelet on to their offspring one of
these is the V alert which can detect if
your kid falls down can you imagine how
anxiety inducing and yet completely
useless that'll be warning your child
has fallen commence feeling bad it's
perfectly normal you're a pen the new
Apple watch is a revolutionary device
but I'm worried it could turn into the
Swiss Army knife of tracking tools video
feeds and GPS locators biometric sensors
these gadgets promise they'll give
parents peace of mind but they do the
exact opposite they create constant fear
fear so great that you believe you must
buy these things or your child is in
grave danger but once you become
convinced that you're happy healthy baby
in her crib needs blood oxygen
monitoring or that you need to track
your team's heart rate on a date which
is too disgusting to think about you
will be a total wreck meantime your kids
feel all the joy of a prisoner under
house arrest saying that these devices
provide peace of mind it's like saying
this box of mosquitoes will provide a
good night's sleep do not open the box
for recent TV I'm Lenore scanning